[Music]
but what is disclosed to consciousness
is still only absolute that is abstract
spirit which is this simple essence not
spirit
as it is in its own self in other words
it is only immediate spirit the spirit
of nature
consequently its self-conscious life is
only the mystery of bread and wine of
ceres and abacus not of the other the
strictly higher gods whose individuality
includes as an essential moment
self-consciousness as such
therefore spirit has not yet sacrificed
itself as self-conscious spirit to
self-consciousness and the mystery of
bread and wine is not yet the mystery of
flesh and blood
paragraph
724 is a very short one
but there's an important transition a
realization taking place in it that we
have been working up to in previous
paragraphs i've brought up well why is
it that hegel
is talking so much about
demeter or ceres and dionysus or bacos
depending on whether you're using the
greek or latin names for them why is he
talking so much about bread and wine and
not quite as much about say
animal sacrifices which we had earlier
in the discussion of the cult and
animals are connected up with
the religions tied in with particular we
can call them ethnic gods the gods of
ethnois of folker of ethical
peoples or nations and here hegel brings
it out
front and center there is a we might say
metaphysical or
consciousness history
based answer to to what we're asking
here
and he says
what is disclosed
right so disclosed here is translating
what is in previous paragraphs for
miller been
revealed or
manifested right so the language is
changing a little bit but what is what
is being revealed or disclosed to
consciousness but wuss sign
is still as he says only
absolute spirit now
that sounds pretty good right
absolute spirit isn't that what the
whole phenomenology is ultimately about
well at this point no uh at this point
we want something that isn't simply
absolute and miller has this you know
abstract uh spirit
and you might say well wait a second
this whole section is the living work of
art we've already talked about the
abstract work of art well that doesn't
mean that abstraction can't be still
happening right so
all of this stuff that we've sketched
out that seems
pretty concrete is still by comparison
abstract or absolute or as he's going to
say in just a bit uh simple einfach
right einfach vasen a simple essence or
simple being
or
immediate and mitelborus uh geist right
immediate spirit which okay
whenever we have a lack of mediation you
might say well wait a second
we just spent the last couple paragraphs
actually not just the last couple but
this whole section
showing all the mediations involved in
the cult between the divine
object
person
and the human worshiper mediated through
things like the bread and the wine or
the actions of the cult or it's hymns or
its language right
here hegel wants to say and this is
where i think we have to keep our eyes
on the prize so to speak right
we've got the spirit of nature
you know and nature for hegel as indeed
we could say
not just for hegel but for
uh his successors as well
nature considered as such
is counter posed to
human
culture which transcends it which
includes not just what we would call
anthropologically culture but all the
other aspects law
religion art these things that we've
been talking about here history itself
right
nature
by itself is something
less
and so the natural
manifestations or disclosures if we're
going to use this word in the mystery
of the bread
corresponding to ceres where do we get
cereal from right
or we could say the grain right
and then the wine the fermented drink
made in this case from the grapes but
could just as well be palm wine or you
know beer or whatever we want associated
with bacchus
this is
it is religion it is religion that is
managing to bring together consciousness
and self-consciousness
but it's not going quite
far enough
and at a certain
point in the development of things hegel
says religion is going to grasp
more
so he says
it its self-conscious life is only this
mystery of bread and wine not of the
other
and here we're getting
other gods getting brought in right now
the other strictly again higher obre
gods
the other deities
and then here he says something very
interesting
gods whose individuality includes is an
essential moment's self-consciousness as
such
so
we've had self-consciousness on the part
of the worship where we've had
self-consciousness you could say on the
part of the cult we've had glimpses of
self-consciousness in these gods
represented in what is consumed what is
offered what is you know given back and
forth as gift but it's not
self-consciousness as such
here self-consciousness as such becomes
as he says an essential
moment vason leak again right so we
could move from
vason to vason leak
of
individuality so the gods themselves
possess
or could possess or will possess or
should possess
individuality
very often
when we look at
ancient greek and roman religion and we
typically if we're being kind of sloppy
and careless just blur them together oh
you know there's uh zeus and that's
jupiter and there's neptune and that's
that's poseidon and you know minerva uh
over here on the latin side well that's
athena and obviously there's some
differences you know the latin nerve is
a little bit more domesticated the greek
athena is a little bit more war like
things were way way more complicated and
took place through a kind of development
the gods
becoming the gods of the pantheon is a
historical achievement
and hegel is tuned into that now we
should actually say we we have several
different kinds
of gods here
one of which is actually
not present
but we've talked about earlier in the
phenomenology that would be the catholic
gods the gods of the underworld the gods
of the family the gods who you know very
often were engaged in apotreptic things
just to try to keep them away and not
fall afoul of them the olympian gods
and of course sirius and or demeter and
dionysus wind up being part of that
pantheon but the olympian gods are
somewhat different they're not simply
nature gods think about what they
represent aries athena war different
aspects granted you've got poseidon as
the sea hades
is the underworld really part of nature
i don't know zeus is kingship
juno is you know womanhood
in many respects
the wife the mother
also ruling over the
the pantheon zeus throws thunderbolts
that's natural but is it purely natural
he's not just a thunder god right and we
could go on and on we don't have to
belabor this point but we're going to
get something different here and here
it's interesting because hegel brings up
something that prefigures
something later on
he says uh the mystery of bread and wine
is not yet the mystery of flesh and
blood what does that you know
immediately bring to mind
christianity right uh now you know later
forms of christianity after the
protestant reformation uh tried to turn
the you know the idea of
bread and wine becoming flesh and blood
into something that's mere symbolism
right hegel's straddling that that very
time in which this is being bandied
about and worked out he belongs to a
religious denomination that by the way
actually uh at least at that time held
that it was still
the body and blood that just the
catholics had gotten that wrong he was a
lutheran
but we could also think about this in
terms of the ancient greek gods or other
pantheons as well
flesh
and blood
who's flesh who's blood human beings
flesh and blood
or
that of animals well we're going to get
to that and what stratus all of this
a sacrifice
of self-conscious spirit to
self-consciousness
self-conscious spirit
that of the god not just these gods but
rather these other gods the higher gods
the
fuller conception of god
sacrificing itself
to self-consciousness the
self-consciousness of the worshipper
within the cult
this undisciplined revelry of the god
must bring itself to rest as an object
and the enthusiasm which did not attain
to consciousness must produce a work
that confronts it as in the previous
case the statue confronts the artist
as a work moreover that is equally
complete but not however as an
intrinsically lifeless but as a living
self
such a cult is the festival which man
celebrates in his own honor though not
yet imparting to that cult the
significance of the absolute being
for it is essence that is manifest to
him at first not yet spirit not as
something that essentially takes on
human form
but this cult lays the foundation for
this revelation and unfolds its moments
separately
thus here we have the abstract moment of
the living corporeality of essence just
as previously we had the unity of both
in an unconscious revelry
man thus puts himself in the place of
the statue as the shape that has been
raised and fashioned for perfectly free
movement just as the statue is perfectly
free repose
although each individual knows how to
play the part of at least a torch bearer
one of them comes forward who is the
pattern movement the smooth elaboration
and fluent energy of all the
participants he is an inspired and
living work of art that matches strength
which is with its beauty and on him is
bestowed as a reward for his strength
the decoration with which the statue was
honored and the honor of being in place
of the god in stone the highest bodily
representation among his people of their
essence
here in paragraph
725 i think you can finally say we're
getting to
the namesake of the entire subsection
the living
work of art and
what is the living work of art
going to consistent well at least in
this paragraph it has to do with
something
bodily something in which spirit
can find
at least a partial receptacle that
wasn't
it wasn't adequately available to it
before this and
it's not happening just
in the community
you know for example
just a paragraph and or two paragraphs
uh before you know with the crowd of
frenzied females the untamed revelry of
nature
in self-conscious form no now it's going
to be
an individual and we saw that just in
the last paragraph the
olympian
pantheonic gods we could say as opposed
to the catholic gods or the nature gods
of the bread and the wine
or whatever else we're going to
substitute in place of that
wind up
being individuals and that that has to
be
stressed now this paragraph is not going
to give us everything that we need for
the living work of art that's going to
happen
in the next paragraph is we add another
important layer to it one that's as
you're going to see you know familiar to
you from the hegel schtick of previous
uh sections
but let's take this up so he says the
undisciplined revelry of the god
must bring itself to rest as an object
what undisciplined revelry of the god
well you might be tempted to think back
to the you know the previous uh thing
the untamed revelry of nature and
self-conscious form the crowd of females
but it could just as well be other
worshipers and hegel here is going to
talk about the fest the festival
taking place through the cult and we saw
in the previous subsection that this can
involve
all sorts of people not just you know
frenzied worshippers of dionysus going
around and doing their their thing
and he says the enthusiasm which did not
attain to consciousness
must produce a work
that confronts it we have this need for
gigan schindly kite objectivity
something that stands against you that
you can use to
to grasp things as he says in the
previous case the statue
confronts the artist
so
where are we talking about there the
earlier section
of religion right we finished nature
religion by talking about the vikmeister
the person who produces
rather than merely the production
of the person who produces something
that could be an idol that can be
architecture that can be a shrine that
allows the housing of the holy
and then we moved on to the religion of
art right earlier and we we talked about
that quite a bit
he says as a work however that is
equally complete but not
as an intrinsically lifeless
intrinsically lifeless statue is
intrinsically lifeless right however
beautiful you might make it whatever
design features you might build into it
even if you turned it into like a robot
right that every once in a while would
say zeus is happy with you you know or
something like that it's still
intrinsically
lifeless
it only has a facsimile of life right at
best here
we want something that is genuinely
living
a living
self
and here's where he brings in the cult
right he says
such a cult is the festival
and cults
they do a lot of different things but
festival is part of it we've already
seen this discussed before right we
decorate the whole temple and the god
gets flowers or garments or whatever
else put upon them maybe we lift the
statue that got up when we carry them
around in a procession right and there's
music and dancing
and food and revelry and all that sort
of stuff that's great
that's that's part of a festival
but
in this case we have an important
transition
a festival of what a festival now here
um you know miller uses the the older
term man right the festival which man
celebrates in his own honor
mensch
so this is like anthropos in in greek
right it doesn't have to signify just
man it signifies humanity
whatever gender somebody might be
and
this is a celebration of
what it is that we are
what it is that the
people celebrating it at the time are
how they understand
humanity which might include some pretty
rigid gender roles by the way right
but that's that's part of their culture
their building so he says the cult is
the festival which man celebrates in his
own honor
though not yet imparting to that cult
the significance of the absolute being
now the cult is being talked about here
is if the cult is what really
matters rather than just being a locus
a place where things are transforming
he goes on and says it is essence that
is manifest to him at first
not yet spirit vason not yet geist right
not as something that here's a key thing
playing off of essence essentially takes
on human form
we could pause here and ask well what
does the god look like or what do the
gods look like and
one answer to it is the gods cannot be
represented right and that's actually in
some respects a ancient idea that we see
arising but it's also a very late modern
idea as well because we do represent
not just you know in terms of
foreshtelling but also darshtelling
placement we we place and space the gods
we could also say well you know the gods
can be
partially human
but partially animal or the gods can be
totally you know foreign to us like you
know
hundred-handed things like the titans
or you know giant tentacle monsters or
whatever we want to be some aliens or
they can be
like cartoon characters or they can be
superhumans or they can be
if they're going to be our gods
they can be much more like us
and then we can relate to them in ways
that are quite different
than just some
crazy monster or
animal totem or pick whatever else you
want no i mean there's things that could
be debated here maybe there's something
that we learn by being associated with
the bear or the caribou or pick whatever
else you want and taking on certain
features of the animal but the human
being has traditionally been understood
and not just in
the greek way of looking at things but
in other things it's sort of like the
universal
animal like the swiss army knife
and some respect swiss army knife does
all sorts of tasks none of them
especially well
by the way aristotle actually talks
about a tool like this way back in the
politics that shows that this is not a
modern thing he he criticizes barbarians
for being a little bit too
indiscriminate that way and not
differentiating properly all right back
to the back to the text right so he says
essentially takes on human form
but this cult lays the foundation for
this revelation orphan baron right a
word that we've talked about before
where we're moving after this
section of religion
uh the religion is a work of religion
tied in with art right the art religion
is going to be to the the revealed
religion the religion of revelation but
we have revelation going on
here as well
so he says the cult lays the foundation
of this revelation and unfolds its
moments separately so we've got
the abstract moment of the living
corporeality the bodilyness of essence
now
why bodilyness
well how the hell else are you going to
have a living thing
right
is it just going to be some you know
airy spirit that kind of floats around
geist in the sense of like casper the
friendly ghost
no
no no i mean we could have dymones like
the ancient greeks did that you know are
the interpreters between us and the gods
that became so important in
neo-platonism
um
but here we have corporeality here we
have bodilyness
we have something that is
alive before us
he says just as previously we have the
unity of both of these moments in an
unconscious revelry
and therefore
human being
puts themself in place of the statue
what is the statute the statute is
perfectly
free repose or rest
right
and the human being is placing
him or herself
in place of the statue or alongside the
statue that maybe the statue sits there
and now it's being upstaged
by the human being
as the shape the gestalt
that has been raised and fashioned
worked upon right the term there for
fashioned i was about to um you know
worked out worked through
uh a hoben raised lifted up
elevated
um
raised in fashion for perfectly free
movement but vague
this is something important the statue
cannot move
we might also say
not only can the statue not move
which makes it a static thing
with which we may invest all of our
affectivity
and thoughts and narratives that that
that's true the statute can actually do
a lot if we're
investing it through the cult
but
when we have a living human being
not only can they move
they can
react
they can
use consciousness
to
decide what to do they can use
self-consciousness
to relate to
the audience the community the
worshipers
and not just provide the same thing over
and over and over again
we could say a similar thing and i don't
want to get too far ahead of us
about like say
film visual representations
there's a certain candice to any video
performance
that
is missing an aspect of what a live
performance looks like
giving a talk
over and over and over again as a video
is not the same thing as being in a room
with students or learners or
fellow
you know
professionals and engaging with them
on things and we can say a similar thing
about the living work of art here
so he says
although each individual knows how to
play the part of at least a torchbearer
this is he's talking about the community
right and this is a very important point
to make
let's not leave the community out no
community no cult this is not something
you just you know as a human being per
se retire into your room and say i'm
going to be my own religious object
hegel would say that's nonsense that
doesn't happen
except for cranks and even they need
followers in order to make it work you
know effectively at all and sometimes
cranks do get followers that's where we
get a lot of cults from right the
community of those who are at least
torchbearers at least
committed engaged participants within
the drama of the festival
and then they it's not to say that they
can only be torchbearers they can be
more than that they could be acolytes
they could be
assistants they could be
uh the narrator they could be all sorts
of things but they have to be at least
torch bearers not just slack-jawed
watchers or something like that
so he says one of them
comes forward who has the patterned
movement
the smooth elaboration and fluent energy
of all the participants
now notice what he says here he is an
inspired and living work of art that
matches strength with its beauty
a very important phrase there inspired
right so that god is involved here
and living work of art
section that we're talking about here
that matches
strength
with its beauty
and on him is bestowed as a reward for
his strength the decoration
with which the statue was honored
and the honor of being in place of the
god in stone he says
the highest bodily representation among
his people of
essence what essence the essence of the
god well yes
but
their essence the essence of the people
this is very humanocentric
the god
matters the god is something more the
god is something transcendent but the
god is so for the community and for the
human being and in particular for the
one who is the highest bodily
representation the uh you know highest
lie bleaker
all right live is is a body
darshtellon not forest
being
you know presented there within the
scope of the community for these
people
that's what's going on
here and in the next
paragraph
we're going to see another very
important element being brought in
you